bild live montag bis freitag bei b
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt die möglichkeit
hineinzugehen
[Musik]
einsätze am limit
[Applaus]
jeder bei den protesten archivieren wir
sehen
live für bild
bild
unser sonntag gehört den sport
sieben stunden fußball
[Applaus]
jeden sonntag bei bild
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bild hier an den rändern deswegen war es
brennt es an vielen stellen
bild
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer spezialausgabe von
viertel nach acht fünf köpfe fünf
meinungen die welt ist mit dem 24
februar 2022 eine andere geworden putins
krieg würde denn der ukraine und
hunderttausend demonstranten in berlin
madrid prag oder sankt petersburg ziehen
auf die straße wie weit wird putin noch
gehen gerät die weltordnung ins wanken
und wird der schlimmste erst noch kommt
darüber möchte ich mit meinem heutigen
gästen debattiert cdu urgestein und der
kanzler der herzen wolfgang bosbach
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer der
stellvertretende bild chefredakteur paul
ronzheimer der iss aus kiew zu
gescheitert ist und den ganzen abend
dabei sein wird und der ehemalige
cdu-politiker und heutiger
startup-unternehmen nikolaus haufler der
in russland geboren wurde und mit zehn
jahren nach deutschland kam das konzept
unserer sendung falls zum ersten mal
entscheiden sollte es sehr einfach jeder
von uns hat eine these mit gebracht die
ihn schockiert bewegt wurde erfreut der
unterschied zu sonst ist dass die unsere
sendung heute monothematisch mit putins
furchtbaren krieg befasst nicht noch
mehr zeit zu verlieren starten wir aber
jetzt sofort wie gewohnt der these vom
konzern
ja liebe nina in diesem moment finden
grausame angriffe auf die gesamte
ukraine statt wir erleben wie heftige
waffen und kiefer eingesetzt werden wie
es dort explosionen gibt wie wir sie
diesen krieg noch nicht erlebt haben wie
wir davon ausgehen müssen dass sehr
viele zivilisten sterben gleichzeitig
enkirch wo ich in diesem moment sitze
haben die menschen angst dass sie
eingekesselt werden eine panzerkolonne
ist nur wenige kilometer vor der stadt
ist auf dem weg 60 km lange
panzerkolonne die hier in diese richtung
fährt ich habe gerade eben noch einmal
kurz vor dieser sendung mit dem
bürgermeister der stadt kiel vitali
klitschko telefonieren können der gesagt
hat diese panzer kommen immer näher und
wir haben große sorgen bitte tut endlich
was die welt muss noch mehr tun sagt der
bürgermeister der druck muss noch weiter
erhöht werden und am ende sagt er wird
alles was wir in diesen momenten nicht
tun dazu führen dass mehr ukraine
sterben oh
ja aber mehr sehen wir dich hier und es
ist beeindruckend
du bist täglich fast 24 stunden auf den
beinen das muss man einmal sagen und
bericht ist für bild live aus der
ukraine aus kiew aus einem gebiet in dem
ein wirklich fürchterlicher krieg tobt
angezettelt von einem aggressor der im
kreml sitzt und wenn man deinen
berichten auch dem was du gerade gesagt
hast auch den ganzen tag über heute
gefolgt ist gestern in den vergangenen
tagen da muss man doch verstehen dass
putin offenbar trotz aller aggressivität
trotz aller bomben nicht so voran kommt
wie er das wohl eigentlich am anfang
doch gehofft hat also es gibt widerstand
der ukraine und was ich heute besonders
beeindruckend fand ist und das hat sich
gestern schon abgezeichnet mit welcher
härte und mit welcher dominanz der
westen zurück schlägt nicht mit waffen
aber mit einer wirklichen geballten mit
angepeilten zusammenschluss mit einer
einheit und mein eindruck ist doch
dass wir so etwas wie einen kalten
widerstand erleben des westens einen
aufstand der demokraten ein aufstand
derjenigen die für die freiheit sind und
man doch sagen kann aus meiner sicht
putin hat sich da ganz schön verzockt
das entspannende these die auch tyler
jan aber die frage die ich mir manchmal
stelle ist die kann sich auch direkt an
herrn bosbach weiter geben in der runde
was hat es damit auf sich es wirkt der
jetzt als wir die ukraine russland
zurück schlagen aber kann es auch sein
dass einfach putin ein viel größeres
ziel verfolgt und sich eigentlich nur
darauf vorbereitet noch mal richtig
zuzugreifen
putin hat ja noch nicht alle kräfte
mobilisiert die in den letzten wochen
die ukraine von drei seiten umzingelt
hatte jedenfalls bis gestern hat er nur
etwa ein drittel der verbände in
bewegung gesetzt das heißt er hat noch
erhebliche reserven und vom typ her ist
putin nicht derjenige der sagt ich habe
mich vor kalkuliert der widerstand ist
größer als erwartet ich gebe auf oder
ich ziehe mich zurück ich fürchte er
wird durch ziehen auch um seine eigene
haut zu retten pauli ist deine
einschätzung von hessens hoffentlich
hören können ich hoffe die schalte ist
immer noch gut wie es deine einschätzung
vor ort zu dem was herr bosbach sagt ich
teile das was wolfgang bosbach sagt und
ich glaube wir sehen gerade in diesen
stunden die anfänge einer neuen
brutaleren grausame rinn kriegstaktik
von wladimir putin denn air china
offenbar dermaßen falsch beraten gewesen
zu beginn des krieges dass man ihm
gesagt hat ja wir werden die ukraine
komplett in dem innerhalb weniger tage
und dann wird die russische flagge am
präsidentenpalast von kirchen und das
ganz offensichtlich ist eine
fehlwahrnehmung gewesen denn dieser
widerstand ist hier wahnsinnig groß
sowohl in der armee als auch in der
zivilgesellschaft als ich heute hier in
kiew unterwegs war davon unzählige
männer mit gewehren die sie getragen
haben zivilisten die da verteilt wurden
die bereit sind hier ein heißer kampf zu
führen und wladimir putin ist offenbar
bereit jetzt waffen einzusetzen die man
aus dem syrien krieg hunter aus aleppo
kannte also diese bilder diese
explosionen die dort gerade in hf einer
stadt 1,5 millionen so groß wie münchen
gerade eben in diesen stunden passiert
sind die deuten darauf hin das ist ein
brutal star einsatz wird von wladimir
putin und wolfgang bosbach hat völlig
recht wenn er sagt dass wladimir putin
gar nicht aus seiner haut kann
möglicherweise denn er muss das gewinnen
das glauben auch die ukraine er muss für
sich ein sieg markieren können und
ukrainische politiker sagen zu mir seine
größte sorge ist dass er stürzen könnte
und wenn er mit einer niederlage hier
abzieht oder einer niederlage die als
das zumindest interpretiert wird dann
drohe ihm der sturz also das schicksal
von wladimir putin zu glauben einige
hängt am kriegs ausgang von der ukraine
ab und da können wir uns vorstellen was
dieser tyrann bereit ist zu tun ich
hoffe sie kann mir mit zehn jahren aus
russland nach deutschland wenn sie das
jetzt zu hören was empfinden sie da ich
merke auch dass das vorgehen der
russischen armee brutaler wird heiko iv
ist eine stadt wo ich auch war
zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine die
menschen dort sprechen russisch der
bürgermeister spricht russisch er
spricht seine bürger an völlig
schockiert und sagt was hier vorgeht ist
mord das ist eine ganz andere stimmung
wie man sie vorher in dem russisch
sprechen den östlichen teil der ukraine
so nicht wahrgenommen hat und mit dieser
erhöhten brutalität gegenüber den
ukrainern hat wladimir putin wirklich
beide teilen des landes die lange zeit
gespalten waren ganz eindeutig geeint
egal welche sprache man spricht klar ist
für alle nicht russland und
nichtgläubigen putin ist der freund
sondern die ukraine ist die gemeinsame
heimat
aber wenn man das alles hört da muss ich
auch nochmal zu meinem postfach auch
schauen der vladimir putin hat ja schon
letzten sommer in einem aufsatz
angekündigt oder geschrieben dass er der
ukraine die unabhängigkeit ab erklärt
wie konnte denn eigentlich die ganze
welt so schlafen dass die ukraine jetzt
in dieser fürchterlichen lage ist das
kann man sich nur so erklären
also man darf das alles nicht so ernst
es wird nicht so heiß gegessen wie es
gekocht wird er wird sie auch schon
wieder abreagieren selten hat ein
staatsführer so klar und seine ziele
beschrieben wie gleichmut den boden die
meisten werden gedacht haben wir setzen
auf politik wir setzen auf diplomatie
wir beschwichtigen ihn und das ist so
ähnlich wie israel er stellt das
existenzrecht des landes in frage so wie
es auch lange zeit zwischen ägypten und
israel war bis ägypten gesagt hat wir
bestreiten nicht das existenzrecht
israels
israel ist immer noch von ländern
umgeben die das existenzrecht bestreiten
dass die ukraine kämpft hier einen
tapferen kampf einen selbstverteidigungs
kampf um zu überleben aber auch für die
freien länder europas auch für die
demokratie in europa denn das muss
protein befürchten die demokratie er
wusste auch keine militärische angst vor
der ukraine haben
ja das ist glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger
punkt und die große frage ist ja und sie
haben es gerade auch gesagt putin hat ja
eigentlich seit 2007 seit seinem
auftritt auch endlich eine
sicherheitskonferenz sehr klar
eigentlich immer deutlich gemacht was er
möchte wo er hin strebt und es ist vom
besten möglicherweise nicht immer so
gehört worden weil daran auch gedacht
das kann ja gar nicht sein einen krieg
in europa eigentlich völlig aussichtslos
bemerkenswert dass die bundesregierung
eigentlich bis zum ende die aktuelle
bundesregierung bis zum ende auch darauf
zumindest ganz klar gedrungen hat keine
waffen in so ein gebiet zu liefern auch
der meinung müsse sanktionen wie
beispielsweise in den ausschluss aus dem
swift abkommen nicht mehr tragen also da
hat sich die aktuelle bundesregierung
wirklich alles andere als mit ruhm
bekleckert umso erstaunlicher dass
möchte ich einmal noch mal sagen finde
ich jetzt wie der westen doch mit
welcher vehemenz auf steht erstmal muss
man sagen vorerst ohne waffen aber doch
mit einem sehr sehr klaren bekenntnis
und sehr deutlich und zwar da geht das
nicht nur durch die politik das geht
zieht sich durch die wirtschaft wir
sehen sportler künstler die aufstehen
und einfach sagen nein und putins
russland muss es ja sagen es tut einem
für viele russen extrem leid das ist das
andere aber putins ostern sein regime
das wird ja komplett isoliert ob das am
ende tragfähig ist und dazu beiträgt
dass putin sich aus der ukraine
zurückzieht ist eine andere frage steht
auf dem papier aber das ist eine macht
die ihm jetzt doch gegenüber steht
zumindest dass diese sanktionen angeht
das hat er so nicht erwartet aber hat
der westen putin auch verstanden haben
sie ja paul sehr gut geht direkt rein
dennoch eine sache was wird mich heute
bewegt hat eigentlich will oder müsli
lenski gesehen habe wie er vom
europäischen parlament gesprochen hat da
geht es sozusagen um die
beitrittsbemühungen der ukraine da frage
ich mich doch warum hat diesem land seit
2014 niemand zugehört das war die ganze
zeit ein riesen thema warum muss erst
krieg passieren warum müssen erst
menschen sterben damit in europa die
politik umdenkt und das bewegt mich doch
wirklich weil 2014 standen die menschen
auf dem majdan mit den europäischen
flaggen ich war dort mit vitali
klitschko mit anderen sie haben mit
europäischen flaggen demonstrieren und
sie wollten zu uns sie wollten für die
werte einstehen für die freiheit für die
demokratie und wollen hat das geführt
europa hat es mehr oder weniger
ignoriert hat auch die bitten ignoriert
dass man ihnen helfen muss sich gegen
putin zu stellen und jetzt sind wir in
einem krieg und jetzt geht plötzlich
alles jetzt ist eine eu mitgliedschaft
möglich jetzt werden waffen geliefert
ich frage mich warum erst jetzt
so richtiger punkt paul und herr bosbach
sie waren ja zu dem zeitpunkt auch noch
aktiv in der politik vielleicht können
sie das baby besser beantworten als wir
alle hier am tisch sagen sie mal warum
erster ich kann das vielleicht mit einer
these verknüpfen die antwort auf dieses
thema es ist bei uns in deutschland
übrigens bis heute die zahl wird weniger
bis heute wird ja die these vertreten
putin ist vom westen von der nato in die
enge getrieben wurden überhaupt kein
alibi geben putin aggressiv zu werden
die gegenüber den nachbarn die
sogenannten putin vorsteher heißen zu
unrecht putin vor stehe denn sie
verstehen putin gar nicht auch heute
noch gibt es ja bei uns persönlichkeiten
die ernsthaft die ansicht vertreten der
westen trage eine mitschuld durch die
nato eingekesselt seit putin gar nichts
anderes übrig geblieben als militärische
gewalt gegenüber den nachbarn auszuüben
die die das sagen haben putin überhaupt
nicht verstanden denn den einmarsch in
der ukraine hat er gar nicht mit der
nato osterweiterung begründet sondern
mit der tatsache dass für ihn putin die
ukraine ein russischer staat sei dass
die ukraine zu russland gehören das ist
ein historischer fehler gewesen sei die
ukraine in die souveränität zu entlassen
was um himmels willen hat die
völkerrechtswidrige annexion der krim
mit der nato osterweiterung zu tun was
hat der einmarsch im donbass mit der
nato osterweiterung zu tun was hat die
unterdrückung der opposition mit der
nato zu tun was hat die ermordung von
regimekritikern auch bei uns in
deutschland mit der nato zu tun nichts
das hat etwas mit einem totalitären
machtanspruch von guten zu tun er viel
mehr angst vor der demokratie in seinem
land hat als von der nato von der
demokratie muss er auch angst haben denn
wenn russland eine demokratie in unserem
sinne würde wäre es das ende der
herrschaft von putin
ich glaube es ist immer schwieriger von
putin verstehen zu sprechen denn kaum
jemand der auf putins seite oder
zumindest als putin verstehe er sich zu
erkennen gegeben hatte hat das was jetzt
passiert es vorher gesagt wir haben
glaube ich in dieser putin kunde eine
zeitenwende sowie auch sonst in europa
und wir haben auch in russland das
gefühl des so bekomme ich das von außen
mit dass immer mehr menschen gar nicht
wissen wer überhaupt noch in direkten
kontakt mit putin steht er soll jetzt ja
angefangen haben auch seine engste
umgebung an zu schreien ich weiß nicht
ob das stimmt wer weiß das schon aber
jedenfalls die zahl der putin verstehe
in russland nimmt auch ab welche
nächsten schritte von putin zu erwarten
sind kann glaube ich niemand wirklich
sagen und alles was uns bleibt ist zu
versuchen russland versteher zu bleiben
zumindest zu verstehen wie dieses land
funktioniert
und da ist es natürlich plan der glaube
an die demokratie der glaube an die
westlichen werte ist in russland in der
bevölkerung nicht tief verwurzelt der
glaube an die nato an friedensmacht ist
in der russischen bevölkerung nicht tief
verwurzelt und dort zumindest wird die
nato von vielen immer noch als bedrohung
wahrgenommen ist man damit schon putin
verstehe ich weiß es nicht aber für mich
ist das eine klare tatsachen nach ihren
gesprächen mit russen die das so klar
sagen und das müssen wir einfach zur
kenntnis nehmen und hoffen dass das
besser wird aber es ist doch wohl auch
so dass die die innere russische
stimmung nach der annexion der krim pro
putin viel größer war als heute und man
krieg gegen die ukraine man muss
wirklich sagen diese grenze die putin
hier überschritten hat ist auch eine
grenze innerhalb der herzen vieler
großes menschen so viele menschen sehen
kiew ganz anders als die krim für so
viele menschen hat die ukraine eine
tiefe möglich im herzen sitzende
bedeutung und ein angriff auf die
ukraine wird doch ganz anders beurteilt
und auch wenn wir die zahlen nicht genau
kennen noch nicht genau kennen ist jetzt
schon klar eine zustimmung wie bei der
krim wird münchen nicht bekommen die
frage ist ja auch kann überhaupt der
wille nach freiheit oder das gefühl frei
zu sein in russland entstehen mit blick
auf die medien repressalien als wir
haben unser chefreporter peter thiede
ist vor ort und ja dann menschen mal
gezeigt hier dort herrscht krieg die
wussten das gar nicht und da muss ich
sagen wie kann man sich denn auch
überhaupt in russland vielleicht frei
entfalten wenn man gar nicht die medien
konsumieren kann man kann es natürlich
schon das internet ist offen jetzt wird
immer mehr zugemacht und über jahre
konnte man auch die norweger kassette an
jedem kiosk kaufen die auch in der
ukrainischen ausgabe rausgekommen ist
als dieser krieg begann und gegen die
immer mehr vorgegangen wird viele wolken
es nun nicht viele wolken den bequemen
weg gehen unsere regierung macht es
richtig die feinde sind draußen und wenn
ich mir zu viele fragen stelle dann muss
sich auch daraus daraus seine
konsequenzen
da muss ich auf die straße gehen aber
wenn ich auf die straße gehe muss ich
auch ins gefängnis gehen wollen ich
glaube viele verdrängen ist einfach gern
und leben einfach nur ihr leben weil sie
wissen wenn ich mich in die politik
einmischen wird konsequenzen haben pa
verdrängen ist eigentlich ein gutes
stichwort du hast ja sehr sehr früh
davor gewarnt was passieren wird muss
man sagen selbst mir kam es manchmal in
villach 8 und so vor dass ich dachte
mit wdr nicht recht haben worüber reden
wir jetzt die gerade am tisch und alles
ist eingetroffen was du voraus gesagt
hast da gegenüber am tisch ist haben
aber ja auch schon westliche
geheimdienste auch gewarnt früher wie
schlimm ist es jetzt eigentlich für dich
und vor allem natürlich für die menschen
in der ukraine das eigentlich nichts
getan wurde und das ist so viele putin
verstärkt die putin gar nicht verstanden
hatten
janina ich hätte lieber nicht recht
gehabt mit dem was ich berichtet habe
oder kommentiert habe wir müssen sagen
wir bei bild seit vielen vielen jahren
angefangen in syrien krieg während der
ehemalige chefredakteur julian reichelt
dort berichtet hatte das ganze ebenfalls
immer sehr klar benannt hat dazu andere
kollegen wir haben immer eine klare
klare haltung dort gezeigt und ich
glaube für mich als reporter war 2014
klar in welche richtung das gehen würde
dann wladimir putin hat schon damals
gesagt dass hier auf dem majdan
ausschließlich nazis seien hat davon
gesprochen dass die kirche regierung aus
nazis bestimmt also hat dieses narrativ
was auch heute wieder nutzt damals schon
geformt und es war abzusehen dass er
wenn er nicht gestoppt würde auf diesem
weg weitergeht und du hast es ja
angesprochen das ist ja alles kein
geheimnis gewesen wie er auf die ukraine
blickt von daher ist es für die menschen
schon wirklich
bin ich sagen enttäuschend ist
wahrscheinlich nicht genug und frust
auch nicht ist ist
eine große traurigkeit auch darüber dass
man damit recht behalten hat und ein
großes drama muss man sagen denn
menschen sterben jetzt kann man sagen
was wäre passiert wenn der westen früher
härter zugeschlagen hätte ich glaube das
hätte dazu geführt dass möglicherweise
ist diesen krieg nicht gegeben hätte das
lässt sich aber nicht beweisen von daher
sind wir jetzt in dieser situation in
der wir sind und da fragen sich auch
viele menschen hier in der ukraine tut
denn deutschland wird nicht genug also
nehmen wir die waffenlieferungen die
sehr spät gekommen sind die sind anstatt
geplant am sonntag dann offenbar in eine
stadt geplant am samstag erst am montag
los und stand heute nachmittag waren sie
noch immer in polen also ich glaube dass
uns dennoch und jan hat ja recht dass
der westen durchaus in interaktion
gesteht aber deutschland dann in der
umsetzung immer mal wieder die
entschlossenheit fehlt also
waffenlieferungen ist ein gutes
stichwort ich habe mich da geirrt ich
gibt das auch gerne zu ich habe immer
gesagt die waffenlieferung in die
ukraine sind etwas was wir wirklich und
sehr genau überlegen sollten wer weiß
was passiert wenn wir das machen dann
kam der große angriff und die
ukrainische armee trotz acht jahren
vorbereitung ihr fehlte es an vielen
vielen arten von material und wie häufig
habe ich mich dann gefragt wenn sie
jetzt in hinreichende anzahl diese
boden-luft-raketen gehabt hätten diese
panzerabwehrraketen gehabt hätten dann
wäre dieser dieses verrückten der
russischen armee wahrscheinlich noch
früher und effizienter gestoppt worden
du hast da falsch gelegen und da muss
ich auch wirklich sagen ich konnte es
mir nicht vorstellen aber ja es war ein
fehler jetzt haben sich glaube ich hier
in deutschland bauen das stimmt schon
das was du sagst auch viel zu viele
politiker immer um
die größte demokratie auf der welt
gekümmert und immer geschaut was da
eigentlich falsch läuft nämlich um
amerika also gibt hier diesen großen
oder latenten amerikas in der deutschen
politik das muss man sagen und es war
glaube ich für viele viel entscheidender
zu gucken was da im bundesstaat
kalifornien falsch läuft oder in oregon
stadt zu gucken was läuft eigentlich in
einer demokratie hier mehr oder weniger
für unsere vor unserer haustür und
welche aggressor sitzt eigentlich noch
ein paar kilometer weiter und bedroht
diese demokratie das haben einfach viele
ausgeblendet und
praxis gerade auch immer wieder gesagt
wenn ich sehe wer von den deutschen
politikern auch aus der sozialdemokratie
gerne sich gezeigt hat mit einem
außenminister lavrov oder auch damit
kokettiert hat dass es gute kontakte zu
putin geht gibt dann ist das wirklich
beschämend und ich hoffe dass es hier
aber das ist hier insgesamt wenn peter
altmaier sehen wie ein werk wie peter
altmaier und werk aufgebaut hat da gibt
es bilder wie putin an lacht also dass
viele auch aus der union und am ende ja
auch angela merkel die diese politik
mitverfolgt hat es gibt das ist
vollkommen richtig absolut richtiger
hinweis dass wir das das ist nicht nur
sozialdemokraten waren wir sehen auch
viele politiker von der afg von der
linkspartei man kann das eigentlich fast
sagen durch alle im bundestag
vertretenen parteien gab es große
annäherung oder gab es zum teil
zumindest echte annäherung auch an
wladimir putin und sehr viel verständnis
für ihn und seine art zu agieren und ich
glaube es muss jetzt auch in dieser
situation einfach klar sein wo die echte
demokratie sitzt und wo die echten
freunde sind und die sitzen in amerika
und das am ende auch die einzigen die
das nato-bündnis dann zu einem bündnis
machen was wirklich seinen sinn und den
zweck erfüllt nämlich ein
verteidigungsbündnis zu sein ohne
amerika wäre die nato gar nicht
einsatzfähig
vielleicht noch ein kleiner hinweis von
von der seite wir wollen gerne auch
gerade vor dem hintergrund unserer
geschichte friedensmacht sein das ist
auch in ordnung und die bundesregierung
hat sich das glaube ich ihr alle mühe
gegeben ohne waffen lieferungen in die
ukraine den konflikt zu befrieden also
das gilt für den kanzler das gilt für
die außenministerin das findet alles bei
mir großen respekt aber wir haben viel
zu lange dem narrativ angehangen frieden
schaffen ohne waffen geht auch wir haben
doch die bundeswehr mitte der 50er jahre
nicht gegründet um andere länder
anzugreifen und zu überfallen haben die
bundeswehr gegründet um durch die
mitgliedschaft in der nato unsere lage
unser land vor angriffen zu schützen das
ist eine große friedensbewegung die
bundeswehr hat noch nie ein land
angegriffen und überfallen um dieses
land zu unterjochen oder zu besetzen und
jetzt in diesen tagen jetzt nachdem wir
100 milliarden paket beschlossen haben
im bundestag dass das kommen soll
sprechen wir bei der eu taxonomie
verordnung darüber ob
rüstungsbetrieben nachhaltig sind
antwort der kommission nein wir wollen
ihnen den zugang zum kapitalmarkt
erschwerend für alle wären heilfroh wenn
es diese waffen nicht gäbe wenn wir
frieden hätten auf der welt ohne waffen
aber wir haben im oktober vor einem jahr
vor anderthalb jahren haben wir über
feministische außenpolitik gesprochen
dort noch mal so thoma über realistische
aussenpolitik die welt ist nicht
friedlich es gibt zu viele barbaren an
den spitzenkandidaten lernt ein argument
erklären wenn man wenn man wenn man
waffen nicht in ein krisengebiet liefert
dann frage ich mich wofür braucht man
dann also dass also werde ich eigentlich
demokratie ist versteht wenn man sagt
nicht in ein krisengebiet in eine
militärdiktatur wie ägypten ist das voll
in ordnung aber wann brauche ich waffen
ich brauchte waffen dann wenn eine krise
herrscht und wozu brauche ich sonst
waffen also verteidigungswaffen und das
ist wird das neue das argument hatte
stefanie erschlossen zu sagen die
ukraine eine demokratie steht dabei zu
sterben aber der aggressor wir lassen
die beiden sozusagen sich allein
überlassen sie sich alleine sind so viel
getan das ist ein unterschied ob man
abwehr defensivwaffen liefert oder
waffen die den zweck haben andere länder
zu erobern eine boden-luft-rakete damit
können sie kein anderes land erobern
damit können sie angriffe aus der luft
ab wäre der gedanke der politische
gedanke war wir wollen alles unterlassen
was der gegenseite anlass bieten könnte
militärisch hatte auch gegen deutschland
vorzugehen deswegen werden wir ja auch
durch die waffenlieferung nicht zu einer
partei in diesem konflikt anders wäre es
wenn auch nato-soldaten in der ukraine
stehen würden ergibt sich für mich
keiner logik wenn ich eine demokratie
dann nicht mit waffen unterstützen darf
wenn wenn es wenn ein diktator regierte
das land jetzt gott sei dann aber zwei
oder sehr spät hat lange gedauert ja
auch weil die anderen nato bach noch uns
überhaupt nicht mehr verstanden haben
wir glauben ja oft immer andere länder
belehren zu müssen weil wir es angeblich
besser wüssten ja eine sache dauert ja
auch schon ganz schön lange und wir
haben glaube ich paul war das als erster
die these damals aufgestellt auch weil
viel nach auch dass gerd schröder mal
sanktioniert werden müsste auch hier
gewichts wo ich saß neben die und dachte
jetzt eine sehr milde these danach
hatten sie alle und auch heute abend
sprechen wir wieder über gerhard
schröder
und zwar macht dass jan schäfer ja also
das ist jetzt
da fiel mir fast die worte wenn es um
das thema gerhard schröder geht also
wenn man sich die letzten 24 48 stunden
anschaut von gerhard schröder der einer
der besten partys von wladimir putin ist
dann muss man sich doch wirklich an die
nase fassen und die augen dreimal
raimund fragen was ist eigentlich mit
den ehemaligen bundeskanzler
los hat er überhaupt nicht begriffen auf
wessen tirol er dasteht als mitglied des
aufsichtsrats des staatskonzerns rosneft
also quasi eines konzerns der putin
untersteht gerhard schröder hat erneut
heute die aufforderung aus seiner partei
bekommen endlich seine mandate im namen
des russischen staates zurück zu geben
er ist heute von zwei firmen sozusagen
vor die tür gesetzt worden als berater
er hat mehrere appelle aus der eigenen
partei bekommen der ehemalige
bundeskanzler österreichs
kern ist schon vor wenigen tagen aus dem
aufsichtsrat der russischen staatsbahn
zurückgetreten beispielsweise weil er
sagt mit dem system mit dem regime von
bei den putin will ich nichts mehr zu
tun zu haben einzig gerhard schröder
hält wladimir putin noch die stange das
ist beschämend für deutschland dass es
beschämend für das ansehen unseres
landes gerhard schröder war unser
bundeskanzler und mein einziger pellis
wenn er so an wladimir putin festhält
lieber gerd schröder dann gehen sie doch
nach moskau westen mit einem business
class ticket
mit einem business class ticket nach
moskau was sagst du dazu
genau richtig genau dass er sollte
verdammt noch mal in moskau wohnen wenn
er so eine politik werd ich finde es
beschämend ich habe mal gerhard schröder
als ich jünger war und angefangen habe
politik mich zu interessieren wirklich
bewundert wie er da durchgegangen ist
bei der agenda 2010 wird ein kanzler
wurde wie wir als kanzler dort
vorgegangen ist aber was mit diesem mann
los ist ich kann es nicht verstehen wie
man sich bilder anschauen kann wie in
diesem minuten hier in kiew in kharkiv
mit den waffen von wladimir putin
menschen getötet werden zivilisten
getötet werden und er dafür sorgt
gesorgt hatte in den vergangenen jahren
dass diese waffen erst bezahlt werden
konnten durch seine gas lobbyismus dass
er nicht spätestens jetzt sagt ich habe
meinen vater im krieg verloren gerhard
schröders aufgewachsen mit einer allein
erziehenden mutter er muss doch wissen
was krieg bedeutet wie viele menschen
dort sterben wie kann er weiter an der
seite von wladimir putin stehen es geht
nicht in meinen kopf ich weiß nicht was
bei gerhard schröder los ist auch seine
alten spd freunde scheinen das nicht zu
wissen da sind ja heute selbst seine
engsten vertrauten aus diesem kreis
rausgegangen nur eines weiß ich ganz
sicher ich als steuerzahler will nicht
mehr länger nur noch einen fällig für
diesen mann bezahlen der verdammt noch
mal mit wladimir putin ins bett geht der
soll gefälligst keine sicherheit mehr
haben der soll kein auto mehr haben der
soll keinen cent vom deutschen staat
bekommen und ich will dass die deutsche
politik etwas tut und dass die spd in
rausschmeißt und dass er dann am besten
das ticket nach russland nimmt
all das ist auch vollkommen richtig
gesagt und ganz interessant ist ja das
ist auch gerhard schröder war der anfang
des jahrtausends kein krieg gesagt hat
der nämlich george bush den finger
gesteckt hat und gesagt hat was man auch
nicht mit mir wie ist eine friedensmacht
sie haben es gerade schon gesagt herr
bosbach ich will keinen krieg und
ausgerechnet gerhard schröder steht
jetzt auf der seite derjenigen der ein
krieg angezettelt hat einen ganz ganz
blutigen ganz hinterhältigen fiesen
wirklich unverschämten krieg der uns
alle fassungslos macht das ist mit
normalen worten glaub ich nicht mehr zu
erklären
uns jahrelang erzählt worden gut dass
wir gerhard schröder haben er hat einen
kurzen draht zu kindern keinen einfluss
nehmen so als wenn gerhard schröder
putin davon abhalten würde andere länder
zu überfahren das ist irre überhaupt
natürlich ist es wichtig wir werden
irgendwann wird der krieg vorbei sein
dann brauchen wir wieder gute
beziehungen gesprächsebene zu russland
aber putin ist ein kriegsverbrecher das
noch nie lupenreiner demokrat gewiss ein
lupenreiner despot gewesen und all das
was die ehemaligen regierungschefs wo
neben einem bundespräsidenten an
annehmlichkeiten haben personal
fahrersicherheit büro haben sie doch
weil sie nach wirkende verpflichtungen
haben im interesse der bundesrepublik
deutschland da muss gerhard schröder
sich entscheiden will er für die
bundesrepublik deutschland in ihrem
interesse in der welt werben oder stellt
er sich für viel geld in die dienste von
putin er hat ja abholen doch kein büro
mehr sein büroleiter der offensive mehr
anstand aus der mitarbeiter mehr anstand
als der chef rechtlich dürfte es
schwierig sein aber ich glaube wenn der
deutsche bundestag in einer resolution
gerhard schröder auffordern würde auf
all das zu verzichten und er eindeutig
oder sich zu entscheiden putin oder wir
das hätte schon wirkung
einigkeit bislang eher runde begeben
sich auch noch zu ihnen herr auf leise
gerhard schröder alles genommen werden
was er vom deutschen staat finanziert
bekommt ich muss mich auch meinen drei
fahrrädern anschließen ich bin auch
komplett dafür ja der druck und der
juristische weg wurde gerade von rosbach
aufgezeigt muss schon erhöht werden
insbesondere auch weil das thema ansehen
deutscher politik schadet ich schaue
auch häufig aus dem osten herauf auf
unsere politik war ja auch selbst hier
in deutschland abgeordneter und das ist
etwas was man uns immer geneidet hat
dass die politiker eben auch wenn es
hier in deutschland häufig anders
gesehen wird es die politiker eben nicht
sich einfach nur die taschen voll machen
wollen dass die politiker eben für die
sache für das land und für das
gemeinwesen einstehen und mit einem
solchen beispiel das also ein ex kanzler
sich für das geld interessiert und für
nichts anderes machen wir auch unser
renommee in der welt kaputt dass es für
mich der hauptgrund gute beziehung zu
russland wären für mich nicht der grund
zu sagen dass man jetzt jeden der gute
beziehung jemals zu russland hatte oder
hat verurteilen und so weiter soll wir
alle die das zuhause haben ja ich habe
nämlich auch gas zu hause wir machen ja
das geschäft mit russland möglich nicht
die manager die da oben sitzen dann
würde ich schon immer differenzieren
aber eine ein eindruck von
bestechlichkeit sollte ein export das
ganze eben nicht hinterlassen und den
hinterlässt er jetzt gerade aber etwas
aber wir sind ja nicht die einzigen 5 in
deutschland die so empfinden also auf
twitter wird der ruf ja auch immer immer
stärker existent im bereich des
möglichen was muss denn jetzt passieren
damit wirklich mal gesagt hat so er
schröder jetzt reicht's ich glaube es
gilt über seine heimatstadt hannover
wenn ich es richtig im kopf habe hat man
sich nicht dazu durchringen können ihm
die ehrenbürgerwürde abzuerkennen und
dann muss der deutsch und bundestag
diesen politischen druck aus um
rechtlich wird es wohl nicht gehen da
gilt eben gleiches recht für alle und es
ist ja nicht verboten also rechtlich
verboten sich in die dienste jedenfalls
mittelbar eines despoten zu stellen aber
ich glaube wenn gerhard schröder
erfahren würde es sind allen fraktionen
der deutschen bundestag die mich nicht
mehr in dieser funktion haben wollen
wenn er privat mit putin befreundet sein
will ist es für mich schlimm genug man
macht keine gemeinsame sache mit einem
kriegsverbrecher das ist aber ein
anderes kapitel als wenn jemand sagt ich
weiß ist das dürfte ein paar
hunderttausend euro steuer kosten im
jahr kosten was is das 407.000 wir
wissen es besser 407.000 muss der
deutsche steuerzahler bezahlen damit
gerhard schröder hier seine
annehmlichkeiten hat ein mann der bis
zur stunde sich weigert diesen krieg
einen verbrecherischen angriffskrieg zu
nennen manuela schwesig kriegt ja gerade
die kurve in mecklenburg vorpommern die
hat gemerkt ist auch völlig falschem weg
und ist umgedreht
stunde nicht da würde ich gerne einmal
ein paar weitergeben herber hat gerade
gesagt manuela schwesig kriegt gerade
die kurve würdest du das auch so
einschätzen
besser spät als nie wobei ich glaube da
hat der ukrainische botschaft da
durchaus recht dass er das als zynisch
betrachtet wenn manuela schwesig jetzt
ihren landtag war es glaube ich in den
ukrainischen nationalfarben zeigt
nachdem sie alles dafür getan hat die
ukraine mit zu destabilisieren nämlich
dadurch dass sie für nord stream zwei so
gekämpft hat also man wundert sich schon
ein bisschen wir plötzlich alles auf der
seite der ukraine steht und das
eigentlich schon immer so gesehen hat
und so weiter und so fort also da sind
ganz viele trittbrettfahrer unterwegs
aber wir müssen ja die situation so wie
sie jetzt ist und es ist besser dass
politiker verstehen was ich für fehler
getan habe es wäre schön wenn sie das
auch mal klar benennen würden und nicht
einfach sagen wir haben uns irgendwie
geehrt nein ist zum ihren gehört auch
dazu dass man sich täuschen lässt dass
man für bestimmte fakten offenbar nicht
erreichbar ist wie einzelne politiker
ist waren aber dennoch als jemand der
jetzt in der ukraine sitzt kann ich nur
sagen gut so und das kommt auch hier in
der ukraine an die demonstrationen die
500.000 oder die hunderttausenden die da
unterwegs waren die klaren statements
der politik die gute rede von olaf
scholz das wirkt schon persönlich wobei
natürlich die menschen hier gerade ganz
andere sorgen haben als was deutschland
über sie denkt und wir sind nach einer
ganz kurzen unterbrechung zurück liebe
zuschauer ansprechen dann über die
flüchtlingsströme bis gleich
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauer starten direkt am bach hat
gerade in der kurz unterbrechen darum
gebeten paul eine frage stellen zu
dürfen das machen wir natürlich sofort
möglich bei uns haben wir es gibt nicht
nur bei uns aber gerade auch in
deutschland eine unglaubliche welle der
hilfsbereitschaft und damit meine ich
nicht das anstrahlen von gebäuden in den
landesfarben der ukraine sondern damit
meine ich tatkräftige hilfe aber sehr
häufig kombiniert mit der frage wie und
kommt diese hilfe überhaupt durch polen
noch in der ukraine an oder bleiben die
hilfstransporte irgendwo hängen weil sie
einfach nicht durchkommen
nein momentan ist es so das hat mir auch
gerade noch mal vor unserer sendung der
bürgermeister von kiew bestätigt vitali
klitschko das ist weiterhin auch nach
kiew einen zugang gibt über den westen
den lemberg reduziert das funktioniert
noch muss man sagen wir wissen nicht wie
es morgen früh aussieht wie es in den
nächsten tagen aussieht denn noch machen
glaube ich die menschen alles richtig
wenn sie den hilfsorganisationen die
hilfsorganisationen die traditionellen
die man kennt unterstützt genauso wie
wir zum beispiel versuchen zu helfen
von axel springer von von ein herz für
kinder um hier den kindern zu helfen was
großartig ist muss man sagen diese welle
der hilfsbereitschaft sprechen es an
es gibt jetzt
mineralölkonzerne die
benzin herschicken wollen es gibt
supermarktketten die nahrung schicken
wollen das ist auch etwas was hier
tatsächlich auch angenommen wird und wo
man versucht das zu organisieren
momentan kommt all das was los geschickt
ist in kiew an wie lange das so sein
wird kann ich ihnen nicht sagen
herzlichen dank paul auf die
flüchtlingsströme auf die hilfsgüter
kommen wir auch gleich noch mal zu
sprechen jetzt erst mal die these von
herrn haufler
jeder tag den dieser krieg weitergeht
kostet dem russischen staat und den
präsidenten sehr viel erstens sehr viel
geld die rede ist von bis zu 20
milliarden dollar pro tag zweitens
menschliche verluste von den soldaten
die so nicht einkalkuliert waren
natürlich auch die technik aber am
wichtigsten ist jeder tag kostet auf
zustimmung in russland es sehr schwer zu
erfahren wie viele menschen in russland
überhaupt diesen krieg befürworten aber
klar ist die zweifel wachsen führende
russische politiker fangen an sich zu
rechtfertigen was sie sonst nie tun
anstatt im angriff eben in
verteidigungshaltung übergehend und das
ist für mich ein klares zeichen der tür
es wird bald einen waffenstillstand
geben morgen sind schon verhandlungen
die werden noch nicht zum erfolg führen
aber nach 23 runden von verhandlungen
werden wir an den waffenstillstand sehen
den coaching als sieg verbuchen wird
wollen dieser sieht man beim toursieg
sein es wird ein sieg sein der so teuer
erkauftes wie keiner und dieser sieg
wird am ende möglicherweise zu
niederlagen von wladimir putin führen
herr haufler sie haben ja auch freunde
und familie sowohl in russland als auch
in der ukraine
wie geht es den menschen vor ort und was
wird die ihnen mitgeben auch mit blick
auf die these die sie gerade vertreten
haben ganz wichtige botschaft die ich
bekommen habe aus moskau als ich sagte
ich komme in diese sendung was soll ich
denn sagen hat mein geschäftspartner mir
gesagt sagt bitte putin ist nicht
russland seit bitte die sanktionen die
jetzt kommen ja wir können das verstehen
die treffen aber auch uns einfach nur
menschen hier auch gerade die die selbst
liberal sind die gegend blutigen
eingestellt sind wir verstehen das alles
aber es tut wirklich weh aber bitte
nicht alle russen stehen hinter diesen
krieg und unterscheidet zwischen dem
präsidenten und dem volk übrigens etwas
was ja olaf scholz in seiner rede auch
sehr sehr klar gemacht hat aus der
ukraine ist natürlich klar jede
unterstützung die bisher angekommen ist
große dankbarkeit niemand sagt zu spät
zumindest nicht von meinen kontakten und
dann bitte noch mehr von kathrin die
jetzt in polen ist soll ich den
zuschauern in deutschland ausrichten
wenn ihr jetzt nicht kämpft dann wird
das böse zu euch kommt ist so eine sehr
klare position also so gesehen kein
einziger von meinen kontakten hat mir
auch in russland sagen wollen dass er
diesen krieg unterstützt
paul du hast die these von heraf la
gehört würde es zu einem piercing com
wird putin geschwächt aus diesem krieg
hervorgehen
also erst einmal bin ich leider muss ich
sagen nicht so optimistisch was ein
schnell waffenstillstand angeht und zwar
deshalb weil
wladimir putin diesen sieg unbedingt
braucht und es ist nicht so leicht das
ganze als sieg darzustellen wenn er zum
beispiel kiew nicht erobert hat das
bedeutet dass er schwerste waffen
einsetzen muss und das bedeutet auch
dass weitere zivilisten sterben werden
und das wird natürlich die wut und die
emotionalität was die
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen angeht
ebenfalls prägen und schon allein
deshalb wird es ganz schwer sein
irgendeine lösung zu finden weil ja auch
kein premierminister mehr mit wladimir
putin redet und wenn ich mir vorstelle
dass er in diesem krieg gezogen ist das
muss man ja immer wieder sagen mit der
begründung dass die ukraine zu russland
gehört also dass er der ukraine das
existenzrecht abgesprochen hat und ganz
klar die gesamte das gesamte land unter
seine kontrolle bringen will da ist es
schwer vorstellbar wie die ukraine
darauf in irgendeiner form reagieren
soll das ist ja nicht so wie die
optimisten sozusagen so grausam das
klingt in diesem kriegsfall gedacht
haben dass er sozusagen nur in
anführungszeichen teile des ostens
versucht hat zu bekommen sondern eben
das ganze land selbst lemberg hat schon
angriffe luftalarm erlebt also ich weiß
nicht wie die verschiedenen seiten an
einen tisch kommen sollen und
tatsächlich muss unterschreiben können
woraus in irgendeiner form einen plan
für das land aufgeht
ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau würde dem
extrem zustimmen was paul ronzheimer
gesagt hat weil es wenn es um die frage
geht was putin aus einem
waffenstillstand aus
friedensverhandlungen mit rausnehmen
kann extrem darauf ankommen was das sein
wird und
putin steht ja mit dem rücken zur wand
muss man ja schon sagen es ist
eigentlich die große schlacht für ihn
die muss er gewinnen oder er ist weg vom
fenster erst dann als kreml-chef weg vom
fenster möglicherweise muss er dann eine
niederlage wie auch immer sie aussieht
auch mit dem persönlichen leben bezahlen
das geht in russland ja zum teil auch
ganz schnell also
also ein pyrrhussieg sehe ich etwas was
soll der pyro sieg sein also und wir
haben auch gerade ja gehört die frage
lässt putin sich abspeisen er wird er
noch ordentlich einen drauf legen
also ich bin doch auch nicht so
optimistisch aus zwei gründen
friedensvertrag heißt jetzt zunächst mal
die waffen schweigen das ist ja erst mal
gut das töten hört auf aber wie geht es
denn danach weiter wie soll er begründen
dass er die waffen schweigen lässt sich
an welcher begründung weil er ja sagen
wir fahren nur zwei ein erster
begründung ist entmilitarisierung der
ukraine da will ich damit ich putin
jederzeit wenn die ukraine nicht spurt
wieder unter meiner kontrolle bringen
kann oder aber ein marionettenregime ein
regime was von seinen gnaden abhängig
ist putin wird sich nicht zurückziehen
also waffenstillstand friedensvertrag
und jetzt sehen wir uns wieder zurück
aber für das marionettenregime muss er
ja den sie lenski stürzen das heißt er
muss in briefen einmarschieren genau er
muss also schon hier auf einen nehmen
alles darunter musik ihren augen putins
kein kleiner weg und würde nämlich ruhm
und ehre in russland einbringen das kann
ja sei nicht mehr eine frage ja
aber bei der vorstellung dass man das in
einem qualitativ schwerste waffen
eingesetzt werden also diese vorstellung
kann ich mir einfach beim besten willen
nicht bildhaft vorstellen und ich glaube
das wäre auch etwas was einem bloody mir
punkten auch in russland nicht verziehen
würde
aber da muss ich direkt mal ein haken
also bislang da haben sie recht sind
nicht die waffen eingesetzt worden den
haag tief eingesetzt wurden aber es gab
raketeneinschläge in dem größten nur
hochhaus der stadt zum beispiel gerade
eben wurde der tv turm angegriffen dabei
sind fünf menschen ums leben gekommen
ich habe die bilder gesehen grausame
bilder der getöteten menschen dort
deshalb was macht aus ihrer sicht den
unterschied zwischen haki wo wir diese
unfassbare bombardierung gerade in
diesen momenten minuten wo wir sprechen
erleben warum sollte er das nicht auch
in kiew tun weil ich glaube ansonsten
wird er diese stadt ja nicht einnehmen
können was soll er denn tun
und dann habe ich es vielleicht falsch
verstanden als ich hörte denn das ist ja
noch etwas anderes ausmaß also das was
wir auch relativ gesehen haben wo
natürlich es tote gab aber mit einem
ausmaß von apple noch nicht
ja ja sie ich glaube sie machen da einen
fehler sie vergleichen leto sozusagen
wie wir diese bilder im kopf haben am
ende des krieges wo alles kaputt gebombt
hat es ja irgendwann auch einmal
angefangen wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen
dass dieser krieg gerade einmal sechs
tage alt ist in aleppo wurde jahrelang
gekämpft ich hoffe und bete wir hören
jetzt in diesem moment
zu erleben ist live mit luftalarm wieder
hier in kiew
das bedeutet dass es wieder anschläge
geben kann und der ja das ist sozusagen
hier ein ziel geben wird nämlich das
gebäude des geheimdienstes
solange wir kein zweiter alarm höheren
bleibe ich bei euch aber das ist das
gefühl ich bin mal ganz ruhig hört mal
rein
dass es reif aus kiew in diesem moment
das ist das was alle menschen in diesem
moment in kirn sirenenalarm mehrfach am
tag meistens tatsächlich jetzt am abend
hier ist es eine stunde später als bei
euch und
das ist etwas was man sich
in dieser stadt auch nicht hätte
vorstellen können was bedeutet was der
unterschied zwischen erster und zweiter
lahm ich muss ehrlich sein wir nicht
erst erlauben höhere würde ich mir
wünschen dass sie jetzt direkt aus der
kamera hier bei mir im studio
verschwindet wo liegt der unterschied
wir haben hier wo wir sind sozusagen
noch weitere wahn systeme und da kann
ich jetzt aus sicherheitsgründen nicht
eingehen aber wir sozusagen suchen den
weg in den keller wenn da ein zweites
wahnsystem angeht und sozusagen nicht
ausschließlich diese luft sirene ist
aber tatsächlich
ist es so dass viele viele menschen
jetzt in diesem moment gerade wo sie
zuschauen wie in den keller gehen kinder
ältere auch das vergisst man die sind
alle noch hier sind viele zivilist noch
hier nicht alle einige oder viele amor
versucht zu flüchten aber ich habe heute
auf den straßen auch mit vielen sprechen
können die sich eingedeckt haben mit
lebensmitteln um schnell sich zu wappnen
dafür dass möglicherweise hier die stadt
eingekesselt wird die schlangen vor den
lebensmittelgeschäften in kiew sind ja
schon sehr sehr lang und die frage ist
natürlich wie lange kann man das
durchhalten so eine riesenstadt mit
lebensmitteln zu versorgen
wenn irgendwann der nachschub eben
ausbleibt
das ist richtig
und das ist sozusagen
das ist sozusagen ich hier gerade mein
kameramann jorgos übrigens just a fist
die nicht mal hier auch reif loben
möchte immer mit mir unterwegs seit mehr
als zehn jahren wirklich guter freund
und besser kann man den man sich
wünschen kann was die versorgung angeht
ja das ist ein großes problem und vitali
klitschko sagt es auch dass
er nicht weiß wie lange die versorgung
funktioniert klitschkos dafür zuständig
aber die logistik auf den straßen heute
haben wir an einer brücke fast vier
stunden
gestanden weil an diesen check points
die zivile verteidigung der stadt
wahnsinnig nervös ist um herauszufinden
wer ist wo wenn man davon ausgeht dass
russische provokateure unterwegs sind
auf den straßen und deswegen
funktioniert diese logistische
verschiebung nicht mehr richtig
versorgung ist ein gutes stichwort
paulus ist ja immer etwas unternehmen
sich selbst das stichwort zu erteilen
das kennst du wenn du hier moderiert das
mache ich haben wir jetzt trotzdem und
zwar möchte ich nehme ich heute über den
europäischen geist sprechen meine these
heute abend ist der europäische geist
lebt bilder von demonstrationen die uns
den atem raum ob prag berlin oder madrid
hunderttausende ziehen auf die straßen
beweisen dass putins kriegt die macht
der freiheit und demokratie niemals
besiegen wird auch die große
spendenbereitschaft
hilfsorganisation berührt ein besonders
inspirierend sind für mich aber auch die
menschen die eigenständige fahrten
organisieren um selbst hilfsgüter an die
grenze zu fahren oder die bürger die
sich sogar in listen eintragen und
flüchtlinge bei sich aufzunehmen der
europäische geist brennt lichterloh die
eu stellt sich auf millionen flüchtlinge
aus der ukraine ein um ihn schnell und
unbürokratisch helfen zu können will die
eu einem massenzustrom richtlinie aus
dem jahr 2001 aktivieren ich finde es
gut ist dann in allen mitgliedstaaten
das gleiche verfahren gelten soll und
die flüchtlinge bis zu drei jahre schutz
der eu erhalten
wir wissen nicht genau was sich
präsident putin gedacht hat bei dem
angriff auf die ukraine aber sollte er
sich gedacht haben die europäer die
regeln sie ein paar tage auf dann regen
sie sich auch wieder ab und dann kommt
business as usual ein ganz großer irrtum
und das wird auch weit über einen
möglichen waffenstillstand hinaus die
europäer eher zusammenschweißen und wenn
er zweitens geglaubt hat dass europa sie
in dieser frage auseinander dividieren
lässt weit gefehlt das gilt sowohl
gesellschaftspolitisch als auch zwischen
den 27 eu staaten auch in der
flüchtlingspolitik selten war einigkeit
so groß inklusive polen und ungarn die
jahr 2015 216 eine ganz andere haltung
in dieser frage eingenommen haben es
selbst in der flüchtlingskrise damals
wurde die eu massen zustroms richtlinie
so heißt die tatsächlich nicht aktiviert
aber
jetzt das gibt den menschen sicherheit
über drei monate hinaus drei monate
können sie ja visafrei einreisen
sondern in einem schnellen
unbürokratischen verfahren
sie werden wohl jeden fall zum weit
überwiegenden teil in den nachbarländern
bleiben also in rumänien tschechien
slowakei ungarn oder eben in polen
ja das glaube ich lena ist beeindruckend
wir haben zu beginn der sendung auch
genau schon darüber gesprochen das ist
europa wie man sich nicht hätte besser
eigentlich vorstellen können und ich
glaube der punkt den sie machen also
putin hat eigentlich das gegenteil
dessen erreicht was er über jahre ja
immer wieder versucht hat zum teil auch
hinbekommen hat nämlich
europa sei es die eu oder sei es auch
die nato partner zu spalten das ganze
thema 92 ist das prominenteste um einen
teil beispielsweise zwischen osteuropäer
und auch westeuropäer zu treiben nun mal
so aber es gab auch andere die
stabilisierung des euro
aber da gibt es jetzt endlich rechte
einigkeit und da hat die bundesregierung
ganz spät reagiert aber sie hat dann
irgendwann auch reagiert gab da die
stabilisierungsversuche
in den vergangenen jahren immer wieder
in dem ein oder anderen land ja auch in
deutschland aus dem kreml gesteuert und
es ging immer darum eigentlich europa
als schwachen kontrollieren einmal
stellen einschalten ganz kurz so ich
muss mich verabschieden wir müssen jetzt
tatsächlich in diesem moment einmal für
zur sicherheit in den keller gehen ist
sozusagen die zweite
sicherheitskette ausgelöst worden und
deswegen muss ich mich verabschieden
bedanke mich für die diskussion aber ich
kann mich gar nicht verleihen ich würde
so gerne tun für guten journalismus für
mode und für den
pass auf dich auf vielen dank wichtiger
ist dass die ukraine überlebt herzlichen
dankeschön gesagt ich auf paul er
das ist immer ein sehr merkwürdiges
gefühl vor allem wenn es bei einem
kollegen aus dem haus natürlich auch ist
wenn man darüber spricht was man noch
tun kann außer in die pause großartigen
journalismus machen das kann ja jetzt
nicht jeder tun was gibt es denn noch
herr basta was man jetzt gerade tun kann
als bürger es ist wichtig dass man neben
den gesten nimmt nehmen sie mal so viel
lokalpatriotismus wird sein dass der
rosenmontag umfunktioniert
2000 der mann straße und blau gelb eine
gewaltige friedensdemonstration das war
ein ganz eindrucksvolle und alles
friedlich
bei aller ernsthaftigkeit
es war toll ganz unterschiedliche
gruppen die da zusammengekommen sind
dass das eine aber diese ganz praktische
hilfe mit lebensmitteln mit anderen
gütern die vor ort gebraucht werden das
jetzt zu organisieren und wir sagen ja
so oft ja so ellbogengesellschaft und so
das war im aatal auch anders er eine
enorme hilfsbereitschaft und jetzt
wieder eine enorme hilfsbereitschaft das
bestätigt sie etwas was mein pastor
immer gesagt hat ist die not groß ist
die kirche voll und wenn die not am
größten ist dann kommen die besten
eigenschaften von uns menschen zum
vorschein und hier eben nicht für
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger sondern für
die europäischen mitbürger in der
ukraine auch ich habe von freunden von
geschäftspartnern so viele angebote
bekommen ich habe ein zimmer sagt
bescheid wenn deine freunde eine
unterkunft benötigen was kann ich tun
ein freund von mir ist an die grenze
gefahren von warschau an die ukrainische
grenze versorgt dort sei tagen rund um
die uhr die flüchtlinge das einzige wo
es noch den sächlichen bisschen daran
mangelt ist die versorgung auf der
ukrainischen seite wo man ja so lange im
stau stehen musste das soll jetzt ein
bisschen besser sein aber auch ich
bekomme das aus dem engsten kreis mit
wie groß einfach diese auch dieses
mitgefühl ist für unsere mit europäer ja
die menschen in der ukraine sind ja
europäer und wollen auch europäer sein
und wollen den europäischen weg gehen
und das habe ich so nicht gesehen war
auch selbst nicht jemand der die
flüchtlingskrise 2015 ohne skepsis
gesehen hat im gegenteil aber hier ist
doch eine ganz andere stimmung warum ist
jetzt eine ganz andere stimmung jan und
auch ein ganz anderer einstellung dazu
also wenn ich das einmal noch sagen darf
dass sich ein kollege aus einer
laufenden sendung in einem
luftschutzbunker verabschieden muss
ich glaube das zeigt zum einen die
dramatik in der sich dieser kontinent
befindet
die
[Musik]
ja muss man sagen extrem besondere
situation der wir uns befinden dass es
einfach wieder ein aggressor gibt der
gar nicht so weit von uns entfernt sitzt
und das paul der zwei flugstunden von
hier entfernt es von berlin aus jetzt
ein luftschutzbunker ist das muss man
sich vorstellen dass wir es ungefähr so
als wenn ich jetzt von hier nach
mallorca fliegen würde das sind ja
ungefähr die abstände und das ist finde
ich auch wirklich aller schlimmste art
und weise bedrücken da kann man nur
beten dass nicht nur unsere kollegen
aber alle menschen in der ukraine da
auch jetzt heil und in kiew diesen
angriff dann heil überstehen und ich
glaube genau diese situation ist es auch
weil das auch so nah ist bei uns dass
man sagt wie kann es eigentlich sein es
könnte ja sogar uns treffen wie kann es
eigentlich sein dass in diesem
jahrhundert nach dem leid was dieser
kontinent gesehen hat sich jemand
hinstellt und einfach sagt weil es mir
passt und weil ich lust drauf habe und
einfachen ego-shooter bin greif ich
einfach mit waffengewalt ein anderes
land an
und knall die menschen ab und lasst sie
töten das ist das macht einen
fassungslos und ich glaube genau das ist
das gefühl auf der andasa dass menschen
sagen du nicht du schwein ich sag jetzt
mal du nicht nicht mit uns
selbst soldaten der bundeswehr in
uniformen werden jetzt in deutschland
anders wahrgenommen auch erzählen mir
dass soldaten die ich kenne wo es über
jahre alt war
progressiver und gebildeter mann sich
wehrte so ein bisschen mindestens
belächelt über soldaten her zu ziehen
jetzt eine ganz andere situation und
auch deshalb glaube ich die politischen
umbrüche im deutschen bundestag die
bundeswehr wird plötzlich ganz anders
wahrgenommen haben sie mir nicht böse
sich sowieso
therapie dem mädchen schon die worte
unterbreche ich möchte aber einmal noch
auf ein herz für kinder aufmerksam
machen da können sie nämlich hin spenden
wir sie mich kurz vorm sendungs ende
bild hat heute schon also ein herz für
kinder deutschen eine million gespendet
und sie können auch mitwirken hier sehen
sie auch nochmal eingeblendet wo man
spenden kann denn das ist uns heute auch
noch mal eine große herzensangelegenheit
helfen sie uns spenden sie auch für ein
herz für kinder dass es bei den menschen
vor ort besser geht kann man gar nicht
sagen aber dass sie dort
unterstützt werden vielen herzlichen
dank und schönen abend noch
[Musik]
lange bevor es menschen gab wurden auf
der erde jeden tag blutige kämpfe
ausgefochten zwischen jägern und
gejagten räubern und ihrer beute
das war ein absolut furchterregende
tiere